hey chbt build an AWS Cloud project for
me sure thing as an AI language model
I'm always up for a challenge all right
so the other day I built an AWS Cloud
project entirely using chbt and it was
actually a lot easier than I expected
all I had to do was type in a few
prompts write a few requirements and
chpt provided me with the exact
step-by-step instructions I needed to
build out the project of course I still
had to go into my AWS console and follow
the instructions step by step but chy PT
made it a lot easier for me to
understand the process and fix any
errors that came up it was almost like
having a personal tutor that was sitting
right next to me and so in this video
I'll be walking you through the five
steps to build any Cloud project you'd
like and how Chad gbt can help you along
the way these steps will completely
transform the way you build things on
the cloud so make sure you watch this
video all the way to the end to know
exactly what I'm talking about all right
let's get into it so first things first
we have to come up with the project idea
maybe you're looking to gain practical
experience solve a specific problem or
just explore a new AWS service whatever
the case though I know that finding the
right idea can be a very tough first
step if you're not too sure where to
begin Chad gbt can help you brainstorm
you can ask for project ideas that
involve specific AWS services or even
emerging Tech trends for instance if
you're interested in machine learning
you can ask something like give me a
cool AWS machine learning project idea
or if you want to host a website on AWS
you can ask what are some ways I can
launch my own website in the cloud the
key here is to be as specific as
possible in order to get the most
tailored suggestions but at this point
you might be asking Lucy what if I have
absolutely no idea what I want to build
well in that case you can ask Chad GPT
for something more broad for example
give me a list of AWS project ideas
suitable for beginners you can then ask
her to narrow down the options based on
specific criteria such as how long the
project would take and how complex the
project is the goal here is to find a
project idea that is not only aligned
with your skill level but is also
something you find interesting
personally for me I really like trying
out new food and taking photos of my
meals and so I might choose to create a
32 web application that displays photos
of my favorite local restaurants but
yeah once you've come up with the
project idea the next step is to figure
out the technology and architecture for
building it out now let's say I've
decided to build out the web application
that can help me track photos of my food
from local restaurants I would then ask
chpt what are AWS Services I should use
to design a 3T architecture for a food
photo tracking web application by asking
these types of questions to chat gbt it
can help you identify the right AWS
services for each layer of your ecture
in my case it might suggest that I use
Amazon ec2 instances for the compute
layer RDS for the database and S3 for
storing food photos however it's not
just about picking the right Services
you also need to think about how these
services will communicate and interact
together and this brings us to step
number three which is to generate an
in-depth tutorial with your idea and
architecture in place you'll need
step-by-step instructions you can follow
to actually build out your project now
this step is kind of tricky because a
lot of times Chad GPT doesn't provide
very detailed tutorials for example if
you ask give me a detailed tutorial for
my project it might just give you an
overview of the steps you should take
this happens because it might be
assuming that you already know how to
set up certain things or have the code
ready for certain parts of the
application but if you're a beginner or
even just new to using a particular AWS
service you'll want CH GPT to break it
down for you so the trick here is to ask
for specifics instead of asking for a
tutorial on the entire project ask for
one on setting up the ec2 instances or
just the S3 buckets or also make sure
you mentioned that you wanted to provide
as much detail as possible by asking
chat GPT to break down the specific
steps you'll get a much more in-depth
guide that will help make the process a
lot less intimidating okay now we're at
the fun part which is to actually build
out the project at this point you've got
your idea you've got your architecture
and you have a step-by-step tutorial to
follow it's now time to put all of that
planning into action so get ready to
pull up your AWS console and start
configuring the services but wait let's
be real here even with the best laid out
plans chances are you'll probably run
into some challenges maybe you're not
too sure how to properly configure an
Autos scaling group or you have no idea
how to check if your VPC is secure this
is where chat GPT can come in once again
you can ask for help on specific
questions and get realtime advice on how
to navigate through them just like
having a personal tutor that's sitting
right next to you some examples include
how do I set up an autoscaling group for
my ec2 instances or how do I check if my
VPC is secure by asking these types of
questions to chat gbt you'll be able to
tackle each challenge head on hopefully
without feeling too stuck or overwhelmed
all right step number five is to
troubleshoot and fix errors let's say
you built out your project by you're now
facing some issues these could be issues
related to AWS services or even code
errors chbt can help with both for
issues related to AWS Services you can
ask specific questions to get to the
root course for example how do I resolve
High CPU utilization on my ec2 instances
and for errors related to your code you
can directly UT the error message into
chat PT and and see what suggestions it
has for you personally for me I think
the best way to learn is to make
mistakes so running into errors when
building a project shouldn't be seen as
a bad thing as long as you're able to
fix them and this hands-on experience
isn't just about completing a project it
can also help you build a portfolio of
work to help you maximize your chances
of getting hired into a cloud role
speaking of finding a job I know that
trying to start a career in Tech can
feel pretty overwhelming but there are
some platforms that can make this
process easier for you I'd like to
introduce you to today's video sponsor
career.com an online platform that
offers immersive programs in QA
automation sales engineering tech
support and more even if you don't have
any experience or background in Tech
Career res can help you learn everything
required to landar your first tech job
they recommend starting off with the
basics and enrolling in this manual QA
course so how it works is you attend
live classes receive one-on-one guidance
from a personal mentor and get real
world experience through a remote
internship their students also get
access to a simplified job search system
and you can read about some of their
experiences on the website if you'd like
to check out their programs I've
included a link in the description below
for 10% off any course thank you
career.com for sponsoring this video all
right this brings us to the end of the
video please give it a like if you found
it helpful and if you're looking for
more ways to learn AWS Cloud using chbt
make sure you check out this video over
here thanks so much for watching and
I'll see you soon bye for
now